hi I'm Katherine mangu Ord with reason
TV and I'm here today talking with John
Taylor of Stanford University creator of
the Taylor rule and the author of a new
book first principles five keys to
restoring America's prosperity thanks
for joining us John great to be here
thank you let's start from the top
what's number one basic idea of economic
freedom is if people are free to choose
what they're gonna buy what they're
gonna sell where they're gonna work
they're gonna hire and how they help
other people but the American system as
it's built up has had that within the
context of a predictability of policy a
rule of law reliance on markets which
provides important incentives and then
finally a limited scope for government
so those are the five things which are
key actually to economic progress when
you say a predictable policy framework
you talk about where we're failing at
that right now in this country well
actually it's filling across the board
it's a funny thing when you move on and
off of these principles if you like it's
not just with respect to one policy or
another but now take fiscal policy we
basically have a debt that's exploding
it's completely unpredictable we're
talking about you know whole tax code is
up for grabs very very unpredictable
monetary policy we don't know what
there's gonna be another quantitative
use and you don't know what the feds
going to do so across the board there's
this uncertainty and unpredictability
and I think that's a problem of the
economy rule of law is your next
principle and that actually that's a
pretty big idea tremendous idea and it's
been a characteristic of the United
States all the time.however laws but
important and so when you drift away
from it it's really a key and so right
now I think there's lots of areas you
know we for example we have this recent
financial crisis where we had a
bankruptcy code in place and instead we
had two bailouts we basically went
around the rule of law and
the automobile company bailouts we
actually put some creditors in front of
others contrary to what was in the law
can it encourages what I calls crony
capitalism and that's a danger the next
point is strong incentives and I think
that probably also ties into the crony
capitalism point yeah the incentives are
important and you can see where we're
violating those like could take the new
health care law as you suggest some
payments are going to be given to people
who aren't as much as $90,000 but if
they are in a few more dollars they lose
all their subsidies so it's an
incredible disincentive to work your
next point is reliance on markets
defenders of a lot of the current new
regulations again the health care law
comes to mind say listen these are
market base what's your response to this
idea that somehow Obamacare or other
things that might look like regulations
on the surface are employing market
mechanisms underneath well it doesn't
you know for example the policies to
deal with Medicare as a government
bureaucracy is gonna say how much should
be spent on this item of that item in
contrast a some of the electives been
proposed by Paul Ryan he's gonna give a
certain amount of money to people and
they could decide what's the best health
insurance for them so there's wonder
relying on the market and one's rely on
centralized government control and it's
a huge difference and your fifth point
which should warm the cockles of Reason
TV libertarians hearts is a clearly
limited role for government is there a
bright line about how big is too big
there's never a bright line but you know
I teach my students undergraduates
whatever that there's cost-benefit
analysis there's sometimes a role for
government national defense security
enforcing the rule of law but there's
also you want to know when the private
sector can do things and better and most
always they can but so often we're
having a government going and doing
things I guess an example but now it
would be this requirement that you buy
health care or that firms required to
provide it in which case you are
increasing the scope of government
tremendously again this is really goes
back to the finding
country where there was a great
suspicion of too much power it came of
course from this monarchy that was
really so oppressive and America has
always been resistant to that and
hopefully will continue to be able we're
now having too much I'd say would be on
the line at this point pretty clearly
this all sounds great
common sense founders excellent how in
the world do we get from here to what
you're describing what do we do how do
we get a vote in the book I have plans
in each of those cases I think sensible
plans and this spent get spending down
to just levels where they were in 2007
as a shared GDP but I think what I also
do is to look at the history I call it
how did we get in and out of these
messes or who got us in and out of these
messes
and you can see periods where
individuals make gabion on their
principles Richard Nixon had free-market
principles but gave in and we had major
wage and price controls
yeah they had Ronald Reagan free-market
principles and he made a huge difference
he had people around him who were
dedicated those principles and he stuck
to them and so you can see periods but
fortunately we have the history we have
if you like a a way to look at what
happened and and I see a great potential
to get him back to where we were
actually I'd say it was a good period
was the 80s and 90s and it's just more
recently where we caught off track and
so we can get back there and we have to
because American could be great again
economically speaking if we do that
thank you very much John I appreciate
you talking with us about your new book
thank you I'm Katherine mangey wart for
reason TV
you